is everybody now attending
okay
the committee has considered all the
written evidence and the representations
made at the hearing
the committee has carefully considered
the concerns raised by the interested
parties relating to the licensing
objectives of the prevention of public
nuisance and prevention of crime and
disorder
however the committee is mindful of the
fact that no representation was made by
ethics police and the environmental
health and that there is no evidence
that granting this application would
compromise the licensing objectives
whilst the committee is sympathetic to
the concerns raised by the interested
parties
it must consider this application in
accordance
with the requirements of the licensing
act 2003
the committee has taken into
consideration the applicant's verbal
representation and the fact that there
are conditions agreed with the police
which it considers will promote the
license objectives
the applicant made reference during
hearing to installing shutters which
would mitigate crime and disorder
concerns
however this committee would remind the
applicant that planning permission would
be needed for this
the committee has resolved to grant the
premises license subject to the usual
mandatory conditions and the additional
conditions agreed with the police set
out in appendix d
the committee would remind the
interested parties that should there be
any concerns or issues
arising from the grinding of the license
which they can contact the license
department to request a review of the
premises license
this concludes the the hearing thank you
for attending